[Applaus]
fleisch für alle immer billiger immer
mehr
es muss in massen produziert werden in
industrieller großproduktion
geschlachtet wird am fließband für
fleisch das nur wenige euro kostet
vielen sachen guckt man ja schon doch
irgendwie auf den preis also ist dann
wahrscheinlich der preis in dem sinne
denn schon doch irgendwie vordergründig
aber wenn man darüber nachdenkt das hat
sich auch star drin weil man dann
wahrscheinlich so was denn wie
massentierhaltung und ähnliches alles
unterstützt auch schade dass man ein
tier schlachten muss ich glaube wir sind
sehr sehr bequem in unserem konsum und
das ist auch dieses problem dass wir
einfach wir haben das angebot ist es
billig wir greifen einfach zu aber wir
müssen nämlich gar nicht was wir im
endeffekt damit anstellen
fleisch hat seinen preis wer billiges
fleisch will nimmt in kauf dass dahinter
großes leid steht immer wieder decken
tierschützer katastrophale
haltungsbedingungen auf in einem
deutschen schweinemastbetrieb wurden
heimlich filmaufnahmen gemacht
die schweine sind in engen kastenständen
eingepfercht auslauf gibt es nicht
die tiere wirken apathisch etliche sind
verletzt laut gesetz ist es zulässig
dass ein schwein auf weniger als einem
quadratmeter liegt die aktivisten vom
deutschen tierschutzbüro wollen die
verbraucher wachrütteln sie kämpfen für
die schließung solcher
schweinemastanlagen für uns ist
eigentlich das große ziel am ende zu
sagen wir haben keine massen mehr wir
haben keine industrie mehr und es werden
keine tiere mehr ausgebeutet nur rein
für den konsum des menschen der mensch
weiß gar nicht mehr was dahinter steckt
wie so und hier aufgezogen wird dass da
eigentlich auch ein leben dran hängt
damit dann dieses fleisch dort liegt und
dass das eigentlich viel mehr wert sein
müsste als er eigentlich bezahlt ich
glaube dafür ist das bewusstsein einfach
über die jahrzehnte vollkommen verloren
gegangen dieser fleischer setzt darauf
dass sich die käufer bewusst sind dass
sie eine wahl haben
für viele menschen ist fleischverzehr
immer noch ein genuss auf dem sie nicht
verzichten wollen
der betrieb setzt auf qualität und
traditionelles fleischerhandwerk
die herstellung der wurst dauert länger
und ist aufwendiger als die industrielle
produktion dementsprechend teurer sind
die fertigen schinkenknacker der chef
der fleischerei kennt seine zulieferer
höfe persönlich wir kaufen hauptsächlich
aus bäuerlicher haltung
das ist uns ganz wichtig dass wirklich
aus kleinbetrieben die uns allen bekannt
sind
das fleisch hat ein wesentlich
intensiveren rindfleisch geschmack denen
manche vielleicht schon gar nicht mehr
so richtig kennen es hat eine ganz
andere zahl in deutschland kam fleisch
bis vor einigen jahrzehnten wenn
überhaupt nur einmal in der woche auf
den tisch
erst mit dem sogenannten
wirtschaftswunder in den 50er und 60er
jahren änderte sich das anfang des
zwanzigsten jahrhunderts gab es
natürlich diese massentötung nutztier in
dustrie in dem system wie es heute haben
einfach nicht und das ist heute das
größte problem daran dass so viel
fleisch verfügbar ist und so extrem
billig verkauft werden kann weil in der
massentierhaltung einfach
wirtschaftlichkeit ganz klar über die
ruhr steht das problem weltweit wollen
immer mehr menschen fleisch essen etwa
in china oder indonesien
weltweit ist jeder im schnitt 45
kilogramm pro jahr in deutschland sind
es sogar 60
die nachfrage steigt je mehr die preise
sinken auf kosten der tiere
immer schneller und effizienter muss
gleich erzeugt werden die globale
fleischproduktion hat sich in den
vergangenen 50 jahren mehr als
verdreifacht und liegt aktuell bei mehr
als 330 millionen tonnen pro jahr
hochwertige fleisch und wurstwaren stadt
willich fleisch seit einigen jahren
liegt das in deutschland im trend
mein appell kann eigentlich nur nicht
verbraucher seien ja ja die macht an der
kasse und einer theke ihr euch dafür zu
entscheiden lieber einen tag oder zwei
tage weniger in der woche fleisch zu
essen aber dafür mehr darauf zu achten
wo es herkommt und nichts gehalten wurde
und dementsprechend auch mal geld dafür
den appetit auf fleisch muss sich
niemand verderben lassen
die entscheidung was und wieviel erkauft
trifft jeder selbst